we have literally apartment complexes
all across the valley that are
essentially doubling their rents at a
time where we're struggling to to make
sure that we keep people housed and i
think that this is extremely concerning
it's not helpful to what we're trying to
do
today county commissioner william
mccurdy asking for rapidly increasing
rents across the valley to be addressed
at the next county commission meeting
yeah the i-team's vanessa murphy
continues to examine housing issues here
in the valley and she joins us in studio
with more
denise and brian many viewers have
reached out to eight news now concerned
about rent hikes in some cases tenants
have faced eviction because they
couldn't afford the increase with the
kovid 19 pandemic and the economic hit
southern nevada has faced plus rents
going up it is the perfect storm
i did i slept in my car with my animals
the friendly first night
corrine cantino says she lost her
business during the covid19 pandemic
she's been struggling financially and
her rent which she was already behind on
went up it's just not right she tells
the i-team the constable showed up at
her home last wednesday you got two
minutes to grab your stuff
and however long it takes to change the
locks and you are locked out i took me
by such surprise she took her dogs and
cat you cannot jump out
you cannot jump out she says she's
trying to keep them in her
air-conditioned car come here my big boy
come on excuse me let me get my
composure this summer's been
exceptionally difficult for tenants erin
mcdonald is a staff attorney with the
legal aid center of southern nevada a
lot of tents are still facing an
eviction crisis and we are hearing that
landlords are raising rent across the
valley according to the nevada state
apartment association in 2018 average
market rent for an apartment in the las
vegas valley was 966 dollars right now
the average rent is 12.37
that's an increase of
271 dollars makes it really difficult
for tenants right now because landlords
are increasing the rent by 20 20-30
percent and a lot of tenants don't have
the ability to repay that increased rent
amount according to the metro police
department more than 900 eviction
notices were delivered by the constable
in january that jumped to more than
fifteen hundred last month
come here little faces cantino says she
slept in a garage the past few nights
and she's trying to find help
this is not what i planned for myself
this is i've never been homeless in my
life
now if a tenant receives an eviction
notice they're urged to file an answer
in court if they've also applied for
rental assistance by law in nevada they
cannot be locked out while they're
waiting for their application to be
processed it appears continue filed an
answer and applied for rental assistance
but she may not have mentioned it in
court and her appeal was denied many
viewers also have reached out with
questions about whether rent hikes are
legal the answer is yes but notice needs
to be provided and we have the specifics
for you at 8 news now dot com denise